I I did some batting I disome batting I
hit a baseball
that came out okay yeah it was a sixty
miles I did some batting having a page
it's a batting cage the ball is at 60
miles an hour
daddy connected I was surprised my bad
speed I have it on video it's so slow
it's depressing I should send it to you
so you can see how slow 16 yeah the only
reason I was able to hit it and I'm on
that and I was so sixty would be my
little school level yeah it's the wall
it's 14 years old yeah middle school and
and I could hit it only cuz I play
tennis - the ball comes over that way 60
I can't imagine a tiered no you didn't
turn it up higher I could have turned it
to up to 70 but I hurt my [ __ ] hands
I hit up and the vibration killed me I
just said it to you okay
and it was like ow [ __ ] so um have you
when was last time you were at a batting
cage been a while yeah but we didn't
start 60 what did you start at well
grown-ups high speed no and I so 60
super slow
dude that's middle school speed so when
you go out daddy hit it well we got a 12
year old throwing balls bro I know you
all your bragging a little bit you get a
ball at 50 years old off a 12 year old
I'll tell you this I was at my boys he's
got this high-end gym my buddy Kevin Bay
at hybrid cross he's gonna be mad at me
fine hybrid fit fitness whatever is
anyway they they they trained the high
school kids going into college the 18
year olds 17 and 18 year olds [ __ ]
huge these days oh my god just huge and
strong I was like how does a kid kids 17
what are you talking sir monstrous
you're [ __ ] monsters dude I can't
believe you bragged about him this six
bring this up though cuz you're gonna be
impressed give it a few seconds then
take me off yeah no but it's dude can I
be honest no the next one has a little
practice I'm playing hard pitch ball
maybe dear I'm saying she's joined a
softball league if I can stop by laugh
at
for that cuz I hit every time 60 I don't
know if you're a throat machine if you
can throw me throw junk don't throw down
the pike is I'm gonna hit it you know
I'm saying especially at 60 from a 12
hill you know what bring it up a couple
miles an hour I don't give off I can't
believe you didn't who was like let's
start at 60 I don't I'm just what they
put it on because I've never I haven't I
haven't swung a bat since I was
literally eight III litters I just
followed watch watch my tip watch how
slow this is do that so slow I haven't
shown dude why would you sell my oh it's
so slow dude I was so depressed I mean I
was a little nervous it's all my elbow
should be higher I think oh man they're
good for you to be least you gotta get
some exercise
thanks buddy it's cool man dude I'm
hitting no huh I'm connecting hello do
you think I have potential you do man I
think you should look and say it with a
straight face no do it man say it with a
straight leg not bitching see some
connecting mother I I was so depressed I
saw I was like my bat slow slow but I
was probably doing it I was it was slow
because I was tired as time it bad you
brought that up to brag
you're lucky told me the speed too cuz I
would have made a lot with see she got
out the other exercises oh man looks
like Hanks buddy that's my calories bro
seriously thanks [ __ ] off dude you look
like Dakota go to one the real fast
[ __ ] ones like the pros lazy you're not
sniffing it you're not sniff out I
scared old one off and it was a victory
oh yeah freaky
let's see laws now or some [ __ ] hey
eighty would be high school level high
school there's kids drop in 90s bro
then the pros must throw some junk on it
Oh fine right
sixty no one's throwing City you want to
flip some junk on it you're not gonna
see the ball if it comes out here could
he know a friend you I'm telling I died
it was I'm talking damn near impossible
I was like oh well how does someone hit
this in the browser yeah and the in the
coach I was I was at USC I'm the
professional batting guys and I went oh
my and I went this how it looks yes yeah
but look the balls he is gonna come
right here right here Brendan so just
try and hit it and do this [ __ ] god i
foul his cut him off you're in the bat
speed basically right or what you
couldn't be the bat around in time I
mean again I've been bad and forever
yeah but I was connecting but it's just
fouling but then that's after like 30
strikeouts now imagine him throwing
[ __ ] junk at you chunk I'm I'm
hitting it maybe well that's why maybe
one out of ten dude if you if you're a
pro you hit three out of ten you're on
the whole thing that's so crazy aim of
losing yeah it's a game of like
basically gonna be so strong here and
then home runs well that's why they
would always give Alex Rodriguez so much
[ __ ] when he's two strike out on the
playoffs in seven I was like I mean [ __ ]
you guys when Kurt Angle and bro and
when Curt Schilling a long time ago was
pitching and he would pitch this sinker
or slide or whatever his curveball it
was it would get end up at your feet
dude it's a guy goes the guy goes he was
struck out everybody everybody everybody
and they go what are you gonna do this
like also Tanner goes what are you gonna
do I can't them hitting baseballs it's
[ __ ] nuts okay at that high level
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]